SCP-682 Vs SCP-826.
These magical dragon bookends can really bring
fiction to life, but could they make the dream
of killing SCP-682 a reality?
A short story written by a researcher entitled
The Generally Nice, Friendly Thing That Can
And Will Kill SCP-682 Permanently if it So
Much As Spots That Damn Lizard - which we
imagine was very cathartic to write - was
placed between the bookends.
A D-Class on a motorcycle lured SCP-682 into
this new fantasy world to fight the Generally
Nice, Friendly Thing, and an epic battle between
the two unfolded.
However, when the battle came to an end, 682
lived, and the Thing had been torn apart.
When it was returned to its containment chamber,
the title of the book had become, “The Generally
Nice, Friendly Thing That Tried To Kill SCP-682
Permanently But Failed”, with almost 200
extra pages detailing the epic but ultimately
fruitless battle.